Шановні колеги трохи більше як рік тому
на початку
2022 року містечко Буча напевно було
абсолютно невідомим для цілого світу
містечко Буча було відомо напевно для
нас для киян як тихе Лісове передмістя
нашого столиці містечко Буча для мене
особисто було те місцем куди я їхав з
рідного ворзеля в кафе куди Я возив
водив малого в класовий центр на футбол
Яке було абсолютно тихим і спокійним
ситуація кардинально помінялася після
цих страшних водіїв які сталися рік тому
я пригадую перше враження коли побачив
ті фотографії з Бучі Минулого року для
мене як для історика ті фото страшенно
нагадували те що я бачив історичних фото
часів Другої світової війни я був одним
із тих хто створював музей тюрмана
лонського там власне в цьому місці
відбулося страшні страти советским
режимом людей яких було захоплено В
осадний моменти перед відходом
совєтської влади так от фотографії в
Бучі вже нагадували кольоризовані фото
1941 року чому стали Можливо ми такі
страшні злочини в наш час в 2022 році
Справа в тому що ми не розповіли світові
вони не розповіли собі про ті страшні
злочини які мали місце в минулому на
жаль злочини комуністичного
тоталітарного режиму залишилися не
заслуженими І так я злочини повторилися
тому що не було
нюрберга протесталіна Тому що Сталін
вийшов переможцем всієї війни Сьогодні
ми знаємо що цей злочин який стався в
Бучі був лише елементом ширшої політики
злочинів які мали місце від початку
повномасштабного вторгнення Сьогодні ми
знаємо що це планомірний геноцид який
здійснює Росія це не просто війна це
масове знищення України і української
нації Сьогодні ми знаємо що цей злочин
чиниться не просто так він є реалізацію
ідеології Русского Мира або ідеології
рашизму тому користуючись нагодою
закликає керівництво парламенту
поставити на голосування дуже важливо
Постанову так само важливо Постанову
заявою про засудження рашизму як
ідеології та практики яка здійснюється
зараз в Україні російсько федерацію
проти українців
переконаний що ми повинні звертатися і
ми правильно Робимо що звертаємося до
цього світу засудженням геноциду який
чинить Росія зараз на українській
території Ми не притягнули до
відповідальності злочинців які чинили
злочини в комуністичні часи Ми повинні
зробити це щодо сучасних злочинів
злочинців Ми повинні зробити все так щоб
це містечко Буча з'явилося в підручниках
історії поруч із іншим містечком
серебрянництва як приклад страшного
гоноциду Я переконаний що наша Перемога
у цій війні засудження Путіна і його
режиму це єдина гарантія того що Ніколи
знову буде стосуватися не тільки часів
Другої світової війни а буде стосуватися
і тих страшних злочинів які нині Росія
чинить проти України тому звичайно
підтримуємо Цю заяву Слава Україні